[Music]
oh so iconic who doesn't love or want to
be bad girl sandy by the end agrees we
all did didn't we well lucky for us
Olivia newton-john is sharing untold
stories about that time in her new
memoir don't stop hood even as well as
how she's thriving in the midst of her
third breast cancer diagnosis and we are
so very honored to have olivia
newton-john right here on our set how
are you good to have you right it's nice
to see you nice to see you how you
feeling very good one thing that you
have done through all this is stayed
very positive every day is a gift anyway
we don't really know how long our life
is and so every day is a extra bonus for
me and I'm very grateful I intend to be
here for a long time I have much to do
still and I'm enjoying my life olivia
was originally diagnosed in 1992 with
breast cancer later it came back and
then again as a tumor in her lower spine
it caused her to suffer a fractured
pelvis which she didn't realize what the
cause of her intense pain where she did
this 2018 charity walk for the disease
and ended up as a patient in her own
Cancer Centre in Australia nobody knew I
was there so I was undercover boss in
the hospital well on purpose I didn't
want be able to know because I didn't
want it to be a you know out there in
the public that I was in hospital at
that time I was learning how to walk
again because I you know I was using a
walker and so I'd wear a beanie and
glasses and I wear a mask so no one
would know who I was
what kind of treatments do you have to
go through what where are you in your
journey well I finished my radiotherapy
chemotherapy is not part of my protocol
I'm on an oral therapy which is hormonal
therapy they take tons of herbs and
vitamins and supplements and and
cannabis cannabis has been incredible
for me for pain and for sleep and for
anxiety and it's
incredible plant that is helping so many
people with different issues
Olivia has waged her war with the
disease over a long period while
jeopardy host Alex Trebek is just
beginning his battle with pancreatic
cancer I say my mace is saying you know
I know you you can get through this and
don't listen to stage boy and don't read
the statistics and just you know stay
focused in and see how you can heal
yourself
[Music]
Greece celebrated its 40th anniversary
last year and Olivia's now revealing
those iconic bad sandy red heels were
roamed sadly I gave them away for an
auction I do decide to wear your own
shoes for the film public is that
comfortable and that with the right look
and you had to dance oh yeah yeah well
that makes sense I couldn't do it now
Olivia's memoir don't stop believin is
out tomorrow
[Music]